The fascinating thing that I've always found
about physics is that it studies collections
of objects and what they do together.
Like water can suddenly freeze, or water can
boil.
Now, that's really interesting.
And you think that that has nothing to do
with people, other than that people are studying it.
But people are like particles.
People get together on a road.
They form traffic jams, which is like something
solidifying.
They get together into groups, which is very
much like particles do.
So the question arises: Can you ever come
up with a kind of mathematics that is like
the mathematics used for physics, but describes
collections of people?
Now, immediately, there's the objection:
Wait a minute!
People have free will, and people are very
different.
We're all very different.
We're not like particles.
But something interesting happens because
when we have lots of objects, it doesn't really
matter that one or two or three or all of
them are individually free-willed.
Collectively, they will act together as a
group.
And that group has actually some predicability.
It's very interesting.
If I think of these coins, if I flip a coin,
I'll get heads or tails with 50 percent probability.
So the chance of me flipping say 10 coins
and getting 10 heads is — well, it's just
really unlikely.
But when it comes to people, the chances of
having people all suddenly appear on the road
at the same time of the day and cause a traffic
jam is actually quite predictable.
It's also the same with, for example, stock
markets.
Stock markets crash, and they rise again much
quicker and much more often than if you were
just flipping coins.
And so the big question arises:
Can we describe how people act in groups,
say when they're doing extreme things?
Can we describe that using the same kind of
mathematics?
And it turns out that we can.
Collectively, people behave in quite predictable
ways.
And one of the things that we've been particularly
looking at in the last couple of years, and
it's now becoming a very important topic,
is: How could people do that online?
Online, people are freer.
They're not kind of bound by who they live
next to or who their immediate friends are
in work.
They're free to explore.
And what you see are patterns.
Very definite patterns appear in a way that
you don't actually see in the real world,
but it happens in the online world.
The online world where we do worry about what
people do collectively.
We do worry about extreme groups.
That's where the mathematics can actually
be more powerful, and that's what we've been
looking at.